[Music]
on this thursday night from crushing the
curve
to complacency rising uneasiness over
bc's rise in cobit 19 cases
we need to communicate with people who
aren't hearing us and the appeal for
celebrity reinforcements
eyebrow raising move what we charity did
just
hours before facing the finance
committee an
out of control wildfire
closing in on an ontario community
landmark diplomatic
deal the historic agreement between
israel
and the uae and forget video
conferencing
magic the future is in holograms
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
para nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us
no matter what phase your province or
territory is in canadians are inching
closer to their pre-pandemic way of life
but there have been many twists and
turns along the way
at first it was ontario and quebec
representing the majority of confirmed
cases of kovan 19
with b.c leading the way and flattening
the curve
fast forward to today and the picture
looks a whole lot different
here are two graphs one shows bc's daily
number of coveted 19 cases the other
ontario's
both illustrate the rise and fall of
confirmed infections
but take a closer look at the height of
the pandemic in ontario
april 24th there were 640 new confirmed
cases
on the same day in bc there were just 72
as the weeks and months passed in
ontario the number of new infections
slowly fell and this week the province
reported its lowest number since march
but in bc there's a whole new trajectory
on wednesday 85 new infections were
reported
leading to a stark warning from the
health minister
i want to make it clear that this
weekend that if you have banquet halls
where private party takes place
you will be seeing environmental health
officers
and people in public health and it's our
expectation
that the limits on the number of people
at parties
will be in place this weekend everywhere
in bc
and should it not be followed inevitably
consequences must follow
the majority of the cases are people
under 40. and newly released modeling
for british columbia shows the province
is trending toward
a massive growth in new cases in
september
the premier's so concerned he publicly
reached out to canadian celebrities to
get the message out
sarah mcdonald has our top story tonight
as the covet 19 case count continues to
creep up across bc
so too does demand at testing sites
where lineups are growing the province
long considered a global leader
in keeping the covid curve in check and
now it's it's it's creeping up again
and that is concerning right now we are
holding our own
recording one of its highest ever single
day case counts on wednesday
most of those new cases in patients
younger than 40.
what you're seeing in vancouver right
now is reflected in the numbers that
we've seen
in the last little while where there's
been exposure events where larger
numbers of people have been exposed
exposure events like the ones prompting
warnings from health officials to the
public
and visitors to this vancouver nightclub
last week
during the same period of time this
footage was purportedly recorded
inside the establishment showing dancing
and not a whole lot of physical
distancing we need to work together
to flatten a curve along with enlisting
hundreds of workers to increase
contact tracing provincial officials are
also now directly appealing to homegrown
celebrities
if i'm being honest with myself i
probably should have just called 9-1-1
to
use their platforms and influence to
fight not only crime
but kobet 19. a call out to deadpool
right now
uh ryan we need your help up here get in
touch with us
my numbers on the internet seth rogen
another outstanding british colombian
we need to communicate with people who
aren't hearing us
of even greater concern is many young
adults may be hearing the message but
not listening
and becoming complacent prioritizing
partying over keeping the pandemic in
check
sarah mcdonald global news vancouver to
ontario next where after weeks of
criticism over its back to school plan
the provincial government is freeing up
500 million dollars in funding
to help cover costs related to the
pandemic this includes 50 million for
upgrades to ventilation
18 million in staff and support for
online learning
and 15 million for new technology
ontario's education minister steven
leche
says it's an unprecedented measure to
combat an
unprecedented situation when combined
with our previous commitments made over
the past few weeks
this means school boards will be able to
access nearly 900 million dollars in
targeted one-time funding
to prepare them for a safe return to
school
ontario's school reopening plan has
sparked protests and threats of legal
action
parents and teachers have been pushing
for reduced class sizes
leche says the money can be used to hire
teachers it can also be used to find
new spaces for classrooms to new
brunswick next it released its updated
plan for the upcoming school year today
and this
includes a comprehensive plan to help
kids be safe on school buses
students in kindergarten to grade five
who are not required to wear a mask will
sit alone or with a member of their
household
students in grades six to twelve they
can sit with someone else but they both
have to be wearing a mask
clear curtains will be installed to
provide a physical barrier with
bus drivers students will have to sit in
the same seats every day and whenever
possible
buses will be filled from the back to
the front to reduce
congestion and to help with physical
distancing
as you may know many children in the
united states they are already back
in school and of course here in canada
we are watching closely
cases of covet 19 there have exploded
among students
more than 2 000 kids teachers and staff
members have been quarantined in five
states
after infections were reported some
schools are closing as quickly as they
reopened
but as jennifer johnson reports that's
not sitting well with president donald
trump
a dire warning from the head of the u.s
centers for disease control
95 of americans need to wear masks in
public
or this pandemic will enter an even
deadlier phase
this could be the worst fall from a
public health perspective we've ever had
over 1500 americans died of covet 19
wednesday
the highest one-day death toll since
mid-may schools are being forced to
close as quickly as they're reopening
georgia's north paulding high school
opened last week with scenes like this
going viral
then after 35 cases the school had to
close there can be steps taken to make
in-person learning safe
but i don't think the board has taken
those steps schools are closing in
louisiana too with hundreds of people
now in quarantine
a judge in houston texas put the brakes
on in-class learning in that city
teachers near new york city have grave
concerns about reopening next month
i would love for the lawmakers to come
down
and just be able to see classrooms such
as the ones in yonkers
you know we're overcrowded
a lot of times there's no ventilation
but u.s president donald trump is still
demanding schools reopen
even threatening federal funding cuts if
they don't although only congress has
that authority
meanwhile in hard hit florida another
masked mandate battle
the sheriff of marion county has ordered
his deputies and staff
not to wear masks even the public coming
in for help can't wear them
despite a county-wide masked mandate
council members held an emergency
meeting on the sheriff's decision
it's a little bit disturbing because
that means i can get stopped for a
ticket
and then all of a sudden you know this
officer could be carrying kobit
the masked battle still raging on in
many states as health officials warn
wearing them
is the best defense americans have in
stopping this potentially deadly virus
jennifer johnson global news washington
president trump is vowing to block
funding for the u.s postal service that
would aid
mail in voting it's going to be the
greatest
fraud in the history of elections so the
democrats they want to give the agency
billions of dollars to process an
anticipated surge in mail-in ballots
because of the pandemic
trump admits the funding is needed but
refuses to agree to a coven 19 response
bill if it includes a boost to the
postal service
trump has long criticized voting by mail
falsely claiming
it would lead to rampant fraud in the
november election
turning now to a big controversy out of
canada and this is surrounding the we
charity and its multi-million dollar
deal with the federal government
the organization says it's now
registered as a lobbyist
months after it began working on the now
abandoned student grant program
our abigail beeman has been following
some key testimony this afternoon
abigail bring us up to speed well far as
the details of this entire affair
unfolded and we learned about a number
of communications between the we
organization and ministers and
government officials including in the
prime minister's
office we was heavily criticized for not
being registered to lobby the opposition
has called for the lobbying commissioner
to investigate
and now just hours before we staff
members appeared at committee
they decided to register as lobbyists
though they didn't offer
context about why now in terms of the
registration for the lobbying act we did
that
it was submitted today um and that was
done
and again just want to say if we had
thought that was necessary before we
would have done it
abigail there were also questions raised
about the money we had promised to pay
back the government
any clear answers today about that well
as global news reported two days ago we
says it has paid back
22 of the 30 million dollars given to it
by the government to run the now
cancelled student grant program
but it's really unclear why they haven't
paid back the rest yet
we seems to be blaming the government
for not accepting it
we're in the process right now working
as quickly as we can with the government
to return it they're guiding the process
they're currently in
a bank account not earning any interest
meanwhile minister bardish chagger's
office tells us the department
employment and social development canada
is in the process of ending the
agreement and they've told we charity
foundation what the process for
repayment is
but they won't tell us why the whole
thing is taking so long
during testimony wee's executive
director said it was a difficult and
emotional
week as they had to lay off staff the
canadian press is reporting the layoffs
affect dozens of people in canada
and the uk and they're looking at
selling off real estate holdings in
toronto
pharah abigail beeman in ottawa thank
you abigail
a forest fire in northern ontario is
creeping closer to a small community
absolutely devastating about 3 800
people have left red lake ontario
they're growing blaze which started on
monday now covers 550 hectares and is
just
two kilometers away from the town a few
hundred evacuees are now taking shelter
in communities like dryden ontario
deepening despair in belarus coming up
the intensifying protests and the
mystery
around one man's fate
[Music]
and belarus huge crowds of protesters
swarmed the streets for the fifth
day to denounce a police crackdown on
demonstrations
protesters accused the country's
president of rigging last sunday's
presidential election
to win a sixth term in several areas
hundreds of women formed long lines of
solidarity
many carried portraits of loved ones who
have been detained
during the protests american marissa uma
lama durham says on wednesday morning
armed forces
raided the house where she was staying
with her boyfriend bella russian stas
gorillic and they took him into custody
they are both academics studying the
former soviet region
and durham says they have nothing to do
with the opposition movement
she says she hasn't been able to have
any contact with gorilla and she's very
worried about him
i could see stuff one last time um
before
you know they had him in handcuffs and
they took him away
um
at least 6 700 people have been arrested
during the protests
and at least two people have died for
only the third time
israel has struck a peace deal
normalizing relations with one of its
middle east arab neighbors
the united arab emirates the two nations
will soon exchange ambassadors and
embassies it comes with a pledge from
israel to suspend
its claims to a part of the palestinian
territories
that it had been discussing annexing as
redmond shannon reports the historic
deal
delivered a key foreign policy victory
to u.s president
donald trump for a president scrambling
with a pandemic
and bad polls brokering this deal counts
as a win
by uniting two of america's closest and
most capable partners in the region
something which said could not be done
this deal is a significant step
towards building a more peaceful secure
and prosperous
middle east and for a prime minister
facing a corruption trial
it's also welcome news this is the
greatest advancements toward peace
between israel and the arab world
in the last 26 years and it marks the
third formal peace between
israel and an arab nation israel and the
united arab emirates will
soon exchange ambassadors and begin
formal trade
the gulf nation joining egypt and jordan
in the middle east
in normalizing relations with israel
it's a
certainly a historical watershed but i
think there's more to
it than meets the eye and i think what
has cemented
this uh has been a mutual
fear of iran in other words my enemy's
enemy
is my friend or at least my diplomatic
relation the uae and israel had
reportedly already been cooperating in
military drills
now that the ice has been broken i
expect more
arab and muslim countries will follow
the united
arab emirates leave if saudi arabia ever
does so
iran could start to feel cornered in the
middle east
as part of the deal israel has suspended
its plans to annex the jordan valley in
the palestinian territories
a plan benjamin netanyahu found a hard
sell
anyway there was tremendous opposition
to annexation throughout the world and
quite
quite a powerful uh opposition from
the jewish diaspora from britain from
canada from america from australia
a statement from palestinian leader
mahmoud abbas denounced the deal
and the palestinian ambassador in abu
dhabi has been recalled
redmond shannon global news london
lebanon's parliament has approved a
two-week state of emergency that gives
extensive power to the military
and human rights groups fear it may be
used to suppress protests that have
broken out
after that deadly explosion in beirut
this is new video from inside beirut's
st george hospital
it shows the moment at the blast a nurse
at the nicu was sitting at her desk when
it happened she was forced to climb out
from under the debris
she and a doctor ran five kilometers
through the devastation
carrying three babies to find a working
hospital
luckily all three babies survived
they were all asleep at that moment so i
felt a moment of peace
when i had them back in this incubator
today the fbi announced it will join
lebanese and other international
investigators
as the investigation of the explosion at
beirut's port
goes on at least 170 people were killed
more than 6 000 others were injured
still ahead why smokers in spain are
about to get smoked out
in the pandemic
officials in spain are trying to curb
kovid 19 by cracking down
on smokers starting friday the canary
islands will ban
smoking in outdoor spaces where physical
distancing can't be maintained
the region of galicia already imposed a
similar ban in cities like madrid and
valencia are considering following suit
spain has the worst infection rate of
coven 19
in western europe there's growing
concern contaminated food shipments
could cause new outbreaks of covid19
two cities in china have found traces of
the novel coronavirus on frozen food
the virus was discovered on chicken
wings imported from brazil
and on the outer packaging of frozen
ecuadorian shrimp
chinese officials traced and tested
everyone who might have come into
contact with the products
all results were negative many viruses
can survive up to two years in freezing
temperatures
but the world health organization says
it's highly unlikely
that people can contract covert 19 from
food
or food packaging officials in new
zealand are also looking into frozen
freight as a possible transmission route
an individual who works for a cold
storage company is linked to a new and
growing outbreak
in auckland officials say there are now
at least
17 infected people a lockdown put in
place to extinguish this outbreak could
extend
beyond the initial three days the virus
had been in check in new zealand but now
there are long lines at virus testing
sites
as concern grows how do they do that
hologram from home next an ontario
company
wants to make meetings 3-d again
a california police officer is being
hailed a hero for a heart
racing rescue
it shows the officer racing toward a man
after realizing his wheelchair is
stuck on the train tracks she manages to
drag him off the tracks
seconds before the train goes by the 66
year old man was taken to hospital
as his leg was injured but of course it
could have been much worse
whether playing police or playing chef
kids love pretending to be adults well
now they can pretend
to work from home fisher price has
launched my home
office that includes a toy headset and
laptop
essentials for the new workplace reality
now while in real life
programs like zoom and skype help
communicate with colleagues
one ontario company is promoting a more
realistic version
of the virtual meeting mike drollet
explains
please unclick your mute connecting with
one another
has never been so easy can you hear me
and frustrating if we're not attached to
a robot
we're in the always entertaining virtual
conference call mr speaker i'm not i'm
not hearing any sound
and yes it works but only in smaller
numbers
connecting with larger audiences well
who knows when will be allowed to do
that
and that's where a toronto company
called art media
is hoping to step in they've used
holograms to transport the likes of tony
robbins and stephen hawking
to conferences around the world but with
less traveling because of covid
they've gone smaller with a focus on
health care education
and finance instead of having to get on
a plane and travel for 24 hours to do a
consult or to do a lecture
or to educate people say in singapore
i'm you can just
beam in do your 45 minutes do live q a
and then if you want to you could beam
in next to tokyo and do this exact same
thing again
so we've become we make important people
really really efficient
in this covid19 world doing a
face-to-face interview like this without
a mask is a no-no
except larry's not here he's in a room
all by himself next door
and he could be anywhere in the world
right now
in 2019 250 people gathered for the
blockchain awards in toronto
the show saw its numbers quadruple in
2020 when it went virtual
and its full hologram experiences fall
is expected to be even larger
we're talking about audiences in china
in brazil in europe
um and other parts of the world we hope
to have an audience that is
is at a minimum 10 times what we were
able to create
using only a physical space it should
come as no surprise that studies show
face-to-face meetings
are more effective than conference calls
or emails
it's just a movie but in star wars
princess leia chose a hologram message
over sending a letter
and look how that turned out of course
there are drawbacks to holograms
nice meeting you larry but in a pandemic
who's shaking hands anyway
microlight global news toronto
it seems the future is now and that is
global national for this thursday
i'm farah nasser tonight's york canada
is the sunrise over the village of kutz
alberta next to the border with montana
if you'd like to share your canada with
us
please email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you so much for watching until
tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]